i'm stealing things
this is thief simulator be very quiet
i'm very thirsty
hard mode no
yes no yes hard mode
i've never played this game before i
always do this i want to do the hard
mode and then i don't do the hard i'm
doing the hard mode i'm doing it i don't
even care if i never figure out how to
play the game
because i know how to steal things no i
don't
lixian somehow make this entire intro
better than it was
at all so i'm gonna play this game and
it's on hard mode
because i like a challenge and i've
played a game in the past that's called
like sneak thief or
something like that it wasn't a
full-fledged game like this i know that
is it mowing day oh my god it's mowing
day
on the game i have to be quiet and sneak
around in
okay oh is that me all right
oh wow
okay that's a little loud why would i
have that up okay vinny
hey it's me vinny pick up that crowbar
and listen
up we got a lot of ground to cover
okay why do you call in separate chunks
they're generous men but they're all
about reciprocity if you get what i mean
let's see if you're up to the job knock
over that house for me
the last one the last one the last one
where
last one which one which last one do you
know
i don't have a hud can i equip this
click quick slot
sure add items to the quick slot for
fast usage go to inventory select an
item and
press quick slot what's my quick slot
how do oh quick slot q ah that is quick
okay which house am i doing
oh it didn't go oh it didn't go
oh that's my hand oh i can't yeah
okay yeah break the planks seems a
little loud
seems pretty loud at least it's giving
me kind of a tutorial
oh and that way i'm actually able to
know what i'm supposed to do beforehand
uh you know there's no amount of
sneaking that i'm gonna be able to do
that's not gonna make her see me when
she's doing the captain's wave
okay oh she will never know
she will never know oh my god avoid
light
how how
how do i do that okay i'm
[Music]
i've been caught tip of the day for the
thievery
is uh when you get spotted don't scream
at the top of your lungs
usually uh not the best move
hey buddy you don't know me here yeah
you don't know
you can't know how could you know oh
great
hey some dope left a flashlight on the
ground some
dope take it but don't let nobody see
the light and call the cops
don't let nobody watch your double
negatives
you ain't never gonna know nobody that's
ain't gonna never help use
well can i not quick slot that or is
that just f it's just
f okay good okay break the window again
i feel like there's stealthier ways to
go about this
but also i don't care
wham oh now i just opened it
thanks for calling me good job time to
redistribute a little well
yeah okay cause this definitely seems
like the rich neighborhood that i want
to redistribute the wealth from
what's valuable to put in i should open
that
slower who's money
oh who's got time clang clang anything
in there
anything in there hello anything in
there anybody there's no one that's
going to hear me this is even the point
of any of this open open open
oh look dollars i too have just random
change in the front room
hello come on lay out of the oh
that was the bedroom oh this is sad why
am i robbing these people
steal some stuff i'll take a toaster i
guess
saucepan what
get in the car don't let nobody see you
with that crowbar
why would i let what shut up
i'm not worried about it it's fine how
do i put away my crowbar
hand right flashlight off
and i'm out of here
i'm gone ain't nobody gonna see me with
this
later nerds howdy neighbor
it's just me your neighbor all right
whatever i'm
open this way i gotta open it slowly
[Music]
oh god good good
all right i oh i drive i've you know
i've been playing a lot more games
lately where
i wouldn't think driving would be a part
of it but surprisingly it is
and i like it oh god
where am i going i drive out of locate
which where
which way and where how and where and
why
which way hello stan
oh i have a i have a gps
sorry at least this car is responsive
unlike some
games i've played but it is just a
relaxing drive at
30 miles an hour no 60 sorry this is
this car goes like
two eight i'm gone
yeah i thought so
five stars almost too easy
oh new hints available why hello good
job man
this just might work go get some sleep
and we'll pick this up in the morning
why did your voice your voice is
completely what is that ex
what what happened to your accent i
sleep on a couch
all right whatever time for sleep this
is hard mode man this is easy
sleep until i guess i sleep
until it's night right i wouldn't go out
in the day
right 8 p.m
get this daylight out of here
there we go now that's what i'm talking
about
there's a few things i need to tell how
did you know i was aw you're
telling me them now tools for thieves
let you buy
new kit online great but you might not
have what it takes to use them all
click on steal your forum
here you can buy secrets hot tips on
what's where
who's guarding it who leaves the door
unlocked
whatever check out what i wrote on
greenview 109.
also your voice is back to normal so
that's interesting okay
easy to break damage wooden fence in the
back possible loot old tv worth a buck
spare door key in the drawer no one home
all the time
so no one lives here is what you're
saying there's no no one here
the martins don't exist no one's ever
home they died
long ago really tragic someone broke in
and
murdered them and then stole all their
stuff so you know
really kind of sad for them all right
anyway hello
to the pawn shop first you'll need empty
pockets at greenview 109.
okay you don't need to shout the
location so
loudly hi what's up i've been carrying a
pie
in my bag here you go toaster
pan teapot hot
thanks it's time for greenview 109.
get me that tv and don't pawn it off
what if i do
what are you gonna do vinnie change your
accent some more
we load it in the car trunk and drive uh
yeah all right
what's my turn at least
i repaired yourself two bucks ain't
nothing that's a pot
that's one single toaster that's less
than a toaster
sorry i shouldn't hit
the i shouldn't hit what i'm trying to
you know what is it what hello
ah hiding spot right of course of course
of course
well time to hit the old blusty trail
and no one's home right wampus
open no one's home so what does it
matter hey what's up bag of trash
okay bag of cash jesus christ give me
give me nice
nice toaster that's good money pot oh
i'm rich
oh sauce pans out the wazoo
god they shouldn't leave their sauce
pans out
oh front door key well that would have
been convenient whatever was this
cash gosh and cash
nice all right oh my god i'll just walk
out the front door screw this noise
la daddy a lot of the trespassing
my ain't oh oh god oh god
oh god
i'm very slow with the dv i'm very slow
i didn't know that there would be like a
camera or anything like that i thought
why would i
get the front door key then oh boy oh
boy oh boy
i'll put it there they were just
throwing out their tv
no
[Applause]
but i was hiding oh my car right i guess
i could have just
ran away well why did i get the key then
it's kind of dumb if you think about it
kind of dumb
that's okay i ain't a dumb burglar i'm
smart i'm big smart
i'm actually the biggest smart uh it's
funny some people did a poll recently
and they found out i was actually the
biggest smart
i was just as surprised as you probably
are now
but honestly were you probably not okay
so
there's gotta be okay so
maybe the thing is because right there's
a light outside and i don't know if i'm
gonna be able to carry this
you know maybe i can't
what if i throw it out the window huh
what happens if i do that
nice almost too easy
i'm sure this would be very valuable all
right thank you the martins
sorry about you being dead wouldn't want
this david to go to waste
i see you around dude see around who saw
me there's no camera there
what the hell was it okay there's no
camera a bunch of garbage dropped that
on there
what it a lot of all right that worked
out nicely
and i'm out of here none
the wiser none the wiser
exactly zero wiser where's my
hopefully no one minds i cut through the
park a little bit it's fine
later oh wait no that was what
but uh where do i go hello uh where am i
how do i get out of this place the
williams who williams why
the wilsons the watson lw
names get me out of here
please tell me this actually gets me
thank goodness okay
don't pawn it they said all right sure
thing buddy
i did it god damn
i'm a [ __ ] beasted thievin
i see you got my screen go to black bay
go to black bay okay all right go there
if you keep your accent
consistent for one second i know you're
a cop i know vinnie i know you're right
on there for the tv go there and sell it
thanks man
where man here man sell man
rent the three now here you can find a
little extra work
i put one on there just for you the one
with the dishes
you mean the only one this is why do i
gotta break their
what kind of [ __ ] am i i'm just a
jerk
now drive back to 110 and break some
dishes with the crowbar i signed up to
be a thief
not an [ __ ] well i guess i
it depends on who i'm stealing from man
i thought it was gonna be a noble type
fine i gotta go to the pawn shop empty
my pockets out
all right well i guess i don't because i
just gotta break dishes
hey use your mouth when you talk please
any lip movement would be better than
absolutely zero
goodbye farewell i go green view where
am i going again i've forgotten
do i have an icon why don't i have hud
thing 110. if i gotta look for a number
like a like a human do i gotta look at
the house numbers
oh earl 107 i guess
one ten
by process of deduction
you have to be 110. oh my god
my big brain is so big
oh no the leaf blowers are coming
oh oh it's oh i gotta go ah
it's this ah oh no wait hang on
god here's the leaf blower good god
finally i was wondering when you were
gonna show up
hey lady how you doing good to see you
um hope you hope i'm not good for you to
see easy peasy lemon squeezy easy peas
thanks for being quiet really appreciate
it
everyone cares about noise here didn't i
get here already why do i gotta break
their dishes again
like this is just mean i already robbed
them i'm gonna smash up their dishes
what kind of shitty day are they gonna
have they don't have pots
they don't have a toaster they got
nothing oh they fixed this window well
that's not gonna last long
haboosh sorry guys look it's just
i don't know it's just the way it is man
i'll take your
you they just bought new saucepan i have
to take it from them
i feel terrible and there's a life
flower
this is hell as hell this is god damn it
well
all right take
their stuff hey you don't even know how
to pick a lock
shut don't learn the basics i'm sure
you've got enough skill by now
oh you're a dick they're way out of here
i don't know man is there a way out of
here i don't know man do i gotta go back
the way i can i don't even remember how
i got out of here in the first place
this bam i'm out of here i guess
i could have just gone through the front
oh
god oh no one saw a thing
how do i learn lock picking you didn't
exactly say how i'm sure
hard mode is making it so that i don't
know how
escape skills i already got it learn
nice i did it
[Music]
yes right now go buy yourself a diy
simple lock pick on tools for thieves
okay i will thanks
i'm the best ever in history of forever
robin from people are already desperate
and broke
okay hey look at that yeah i'll do that
all right i did it before you get
yourself into trouble
try it on a training lock i left one in
the garage
what's with your accent man you got to
keep that consistent man that is not
okay
oh it's like oh it's like a skyrim
oh man i have not done it like this in a
long time
[Music]
you did a good job on that old tv in the
empty house
for a real job you gotta scope the joint
go to 111 by 7 am and watch okay
sure man whatever you say man man this
whole being a thief thing sure is a lot
of work if i hadn't known that i
wouldn't have taken it up
that's ridiculous also why do i hit the
same goddamn
houses every single time they're gonna
find out
tenant routines okay oh
ah interesting wait there's more police
pursuit
that's not important i don't even care
i'm speeding oh the handling on this
thing is a beast
all right let me just uh default middle
mouse button
oh yeah this is inconspicuous all right
hey you pooping
you poop in there there's a box in there
wait for them to leave and get me that
box
you're pooping sleeping in the parking
lot sleep in the car to pass a lot of
time
oh he up he done pooping you gonna wipe
oh he's quick
he's like crypted fast i don't trust
this guy seems terrifying
okay so one is out and one is in the
living room so i just gotta wait until
this guy goes
out he's back to poop that's good
okay i'll just no one will notice me
here in the middle of the street right
uh sleepless how do i sl
how do how do i sleep you didn't say how
sleeping in the parking lot close my
eyes i guess
hey what's up okay hey what's up how are
you doing you live there you better not
how do i go to sleep
parking lot i'm sorry parking lot
oh
is that long enough might not have been
long enough hello
it was perfect perfect amount of time
i'll go in the back
hello anybody home the answer is no oh i
gotta pick the lock that's right okay
that makes sense okay oh
oh oh
get me open baby all right
still you almost steal your beer who
puts beer
what psychotic freak puts beer in a
why is beer there i can't carry that
i need to keep my hands free 50 50 bucks
damn okay box with shady content
i don't want to know i'll take this tv
though lot of
lotta lotta d lotta do
a lot of a lot to do okay and uh drop it
and drop it and drop it close that up
should i re-lock it can i just go out
the front
seems like i can
no one notices you do not notice a thing
i should have parked closer i should
have brought the car around just uh
just walking with the tv i'm just
watching taking my tv for a walk
everyone
come on shut up boy mind your own
business it's america
free key i am out of here
okay hey looks like someone is free and
that's me i'm the free one
because america shut up you are not
free to blast your leaf blower god damn
look at
oh my god b
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] black bear wanted
other yamaha guitar
okay so am i supposed to be just on the
lookout for this kind of stuff
gift red oh my god i just gotta
steal christmas i gotta steal christmas
oh
no that's sad why do i gotta do that i
got a radio
sell that uh oh yeah oh yeah someone
really wants this old toaster hey vinnie
think their friend on green view needs a
new window
but they think the one they got is fine
go prove them wrong what kind of
what what is this an argument do i need
who are the lombardies is this i already
accepted apparently
thanks vinnie for filling that out i'm
just gonna go break a window do i need a
mask it's kind of broad daylight you
know
all right what am i doing 112 god these
neighbors are going to talk to each
other eventually i don't know who the
lombardies are
but man they are petty
hey yo my god okay 111 is there where's
112 then
okay are you one twelve oh god damn it
112. hello 108 where's 112
don't you hide it from me
hello how are you guys
oh legitimately terrified me do i have a
map
no math map 1
12. oh that picture okay it's a blue
house okay so i'm looking for
it looks like it's kind of like up on a
hill or something is that
wait that's kind of bluish 112.
one two goddammit okay fine thank you
break their window all right well i lost
a dollar but whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm out of here
okay i'm out i'm out i'm out baby i'm
out i'm gone baby i'm gone i'm gone i'm
gone
oh god damn it feels good to be bad okay
so i i i need to buy a
a lock pick a real one a big boy lock
pick
all right oh my god you
are an [ __ ]
i see okay
i thought i had that
interesting i don't know if that's how
locks work but that was cool if it ain't
broke
fix it with a crowbar word on the street
as the toilet in greenview 113
is not broke well again this seems like
just dick work to do but
why do i need to break someone's toilet
i'm going to greenview to break a toilet
this is what my life has turned out to i
gotta bailed out of prison for this
all right 113 wherever that was um
when they're dean oh one of they're
doing the pals okay all right guys
okay hey where's your turlet where if
you had a turtle
where would you say it would be oh my
god
i'm assuming they're in oh like here
oh my god jesus christ everyone here is
encrypted
oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god here we go i'm going
for it
ah where's your toilet give me your
toilet oh god this is a problem
don't mind me just gonna go break your
toilet dude hold on i gotta
get you why'd you lock this door this is
weird there we go okay where's your
toilet where's your toilet i gotta go
where's your toilet where is it oh my
god where's your toilet
do you have a toilet i gotta go so bad i
might break it here i go
oh god i'm taking a [ __ ] ah oh it's all
done
whoa thanks buddy okay
later nerds goo
my god oh that's really
glad i did that sorry um
go away you have a lovely house
and a free i did it okay good
that was a close one for the next task i
need you to learn how to climb
a lattice like a man spider you know
you're telling me that i don't know how
to climb a lettuce
job accepted break their toilet i
thought i just did that
didn't oh my god i'm freaking lethal
didn't i just
do that all right fine
oh man that's ex that's freaking
expensive okay i gotta go
actually steal some stuff i'm gonna do
it all legit i'm gonna get there
butt crack dawn i'm gonna scout the
place out
i'm gonna look and i'm gonna look for
the biggest most expensive house
in the neighborhood i'm gonna scout it
out i'm gonna figure out the routine
i'm going to sleep in the parking lot
and then i'm going to
rob them blind and then i will blind
them
so that they can't tell whoever stole
from them again
all right so it's all about finding the
right toe my god look at that
ow maybe not that target maybe not that
maybe not that one
hmm it does look good though does look
good
you know you gotta admit it it do look
good it do
look good don't mind me making a few uh
just testing out the off-roading this
isn't your property line so what do you
care
are you upset shut up go away this seems
like a good spot to make a clean getaway
some kind of electrical box here i
better check that out
never know what you could find mini
electric lock pick that would be too
easy
i don't want to be that easy yeah
well i better go around i'll leave it
right here
no one will ever suspect a thing all
right
just uh friendly door-to-door or
something something salesman's
the smiths huh well
looks like this lock would be almost too
easy
hello looks like they're not even home
what does this do please oh camera okay
well
i don't need to worry about that oh
how wait i'm not no no not me not me
no not not me no how do i get out of
okay it not
me man not me guys please
stop can i hide in a bush or something
can i can i bush out where's my car i
forgot where my car is
oh where's my car oh there it is you
found it thank you officer
okay my mistake was not waiting until
night time forgot that was like a step
don't worry let's see just edit around
it uh make it seem like i knew that
first time
okay now that i've scouted out that
entire place
and i know the ins and outs of all the
intricacies of the how they live and
where they are
i will now go sleep in the parking lot
until night time
the butt crack of dawn as i said before
and i stuck to my plan real good
and then i will rob them blind perfect
just as usual my ability to sleep 14
hours in a row at any given time is
really comes in handy don't mind my car
here
it's here for a reason maybe i shouldn't
get this one
there seems to be a bright light in the
middle of the everything
whoa oh did they just leave their house
oh my god did they just like
oh my god they just left their house
didn't they oh [ __ ]
i should point this in the other
direction but i won't because i i'm so
confident
in myself just going for my
daily sprints you know it's a couple
daily sprints you know keeps the
i can't even lift that i'm not agile
enough oh hey
neighbor how you doing just you know i
like the feel of leaves on my
back very refreshing hey what's up guys
how you doing buddies
you all look so good
hey snake mode engaged
yawn yawn okay
they seem to have steel reinforced
windows which is peculiar
i would say that's really interesting oh
that
um hi
oh i can't i can't have you you just
exist
there's got to be some window that's a
little bit vulnerable here there's got
to be oh my god is there not
really should have gone for the front
door they don't have a back door
can i take their grill something's over
there
what is that
almost too easy almost too easy payday
baby payday
okay
seems like not many people are out and
about maybe it finally got early enough
that people went to bed
okay let's see about this front dorky
why i
how do you get it what is this place
what's this
impenetrable fortress all right you know
what uh hey well i wouldn't do nothing
what are you doing who are you get out
of this place i don't trust you you're
weird this is our neighborhood i'm
watching i'm
neighborhood watch watch out i'm
watching you
i'm watching you what are you doing
standing out in front that's weird if
i'm watching you
watching
[Music]
nice nice
nice almost too
easy almost two
oh is that an open window oh
no someone should have paid more
attention
in on being thieved school
hint discovered yeah they leave the
window open in the back
oh yeah safe cracking would be cool
i can't see anything i'm
taking this i'm opening these
look hard drive not a book almost too
easy you know shoes probably actually
would sell
depending on what type of shoe it would
sell pretty well
i don't know why i'm not taking them
oh my god a sweet camera yes please
my dude anything in the bathroom they
got cash lying around should i break
your toilet i would
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay i'm gonna try to go upstairs i know
they're sleeping there but
maybe that means no one's upstairs
could that ka-ching be any louder oh my
god is it
day is day happening yeah take your
remote idiot
good luck changing i hope that alarm
clock isn't
set okay i think my bag's full it looks
like my bag's full
no but there's still room for dosh okay
uh
gosh please all right i'm out of here
i'm out of here it's like day
um i should probably have been out of
here a little bit ago but
hope they don't get up early it's 6 a.m
time for
school
nothing to do here with me
bam oh my god
i've just got stuck on a bush button oh
my god
i am incredible
no one detected a thing i'm a beast
i should sell on the website first
oh oh i should i should go to the way oh
shut up you you're my last resort shut
up and go away i'll
never be happy to see you i should go
sell on the website first because i
think there's more money to be made
there
than anywhere else that was fun that was
good i like that that was good
okay electronics uh no nothing and did i
get anything that you could
all right well apparently no okay thanks
for wasting my time
gotta go crawling back to the pawn shop
guy yeah this is gonna be
awkward okay hey
[Music]
thank you love the way you don't move
any part of you
oh i got some good stuff heady phonies
usb
flash drive a noke
a hard drive camouflage remote
they're never going to be able to
control the tv and an alarm clock
very stained okay
good thank you lexie and give them a
smooch
come on let's listen give them a smooch
just come on give us a better deal
okay thank you thank you could have been
on the lips but whatever you know i'm
not gonna judge
okay any uh any uh jabs any uh
jabs are there jabs rent a thug
ooh break or steal the kiss painting
that is a horrible kiss got a good bit
of money wait let me see
let me see what i can level up first let
me see what i can level up skills
okay so i can get agility right
i can throw br great
okay doesn't matter it's not important
okay so what i need to do now
is i need to level up one more time
which means that i got to pull off
another
crime heist of the century
i guess well i should uh i should uh
get some info on some of these people
and then i would know exactly what i'm
in for that's the whole point of this
let's go for the
powells yeah
okay no one between nine and two spare
key for the front door in the bedroom
looks like i'm getting there between uh
it's now
now's the time well pals at
was the street notes pals pals at 113
you are done for dunyan rings
you're done everything your kid's
college fund
gone your entire life savings evaporated
your whole dream vacations
eroded away you will have nothing you
it's you
ah it's you you got a lot of art in
there okay 909 i'll see you later
have a good day at work have a good day
okay
later nerd idiot
i thought these broke that's why i
brought bought two of them but
apparently not
so i could just throw a brick oh no
nevermind
oh yeah these people i woke up rudely
that's right i woke them up
okay so then no one's home so i could
just ransack to my heart's content you
know
really just go for it yeah you know and
i will i will
no two alarm clocks and a spare just in
case they don't wake up
i get it i've been there whoa last cup
uh two dollars that's not very much
i'm going for the big ticket items
immediately
like dollars yes but seven
oh my god i'm full wait now i'm full
how much are you 12 oh my god
everything's so heavy i'm so weak i can
barely throw a brick
why do i gotta this is what i just
lockpicked to break your toilet but no i
got
they learned their lesson relocked it
what if they have to go to the bathroom
in the middle of the night and there you
think they're gonna sit here and unlock
pick their own
no just gonna unlock the front door
ooh okay so i'd have to carry that
manually
well i could always put stuff in my car
because no one's here
yeah no no one's here no one knows
yeah because i do have storage right
yeah yeah yeah hero uh i knew
that uh they were
wow yeah yeah easy okay let's go in and
out i'm
moving stuff for them you don't know i'm
not
fool jomaha okay i still got time before
they come back
dog pillow can i steal their pillows
they deserve it have you seen these
people they deserve it
priceless family portrait nope
yes please presents yeah
i'll take that thank you oh christmas
ain't coming this year christmas is not
coming this year christmas
ain't coming for you is it full
is it full of it is it full over there
is it full is it full
are you full okay it looks like i'm kind
of loaded to the tits
hi stan
sure could use a glass of water all
right just
you know everybody shut up
no no no no no not doing anything shady
oh no come on dude dude
boys very slow oh my god they're coming
oh my god we gotta go we gotta go get it
get it in get it in
get it in close get in go go go go go go
go go go go go
no i set the way yes oh my god no no
oh
made it you
all are so dumb i am
so goddamn good at what i do
i oh my god
everything oh sell please sell it i have
to get many gifts but that's okay
it's all right so i think that's going
to do it for now
i'm very proud of myself in the life
that i've chosen clearly i've made the
right decisions in life
and uh you know just in in general yeah
i'm the best
everyone else is a loser there you have
it straight from the horse's mouth thank
you everybody so much for watching
crime does pay apparently crime does pay
let me know what you think of crime and
crime in general down in the comments
below
hope you enjoyed this there's another
thieving game that i'll probably link
either in the end cards or in the
description down there that you can
check out that i played a long time ago
see how i've progressed
as a thief thank you and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
oh